[Music]
this video is sponsored by movie go to
movie.com
thomasflight for your extended 30-day
free trial i think one of the funniest
moments in the grand budapest hotel is
this
she's been murdered and you think i did
it
right gustav h who presents himself as
being so dignified and elegant suddenly
sprints away
in a ridiculous attempt to flee the
authorities but did you know his run is
a reference to the 1963 ingmar bergman
film the silence
the silence is set in a hotel in an
unnamed eastern european country on the
brink of war
seem familiar in the director's
commentary for the grand budapest hotel
anderson mentions it as an influence he
doesn't mention this run
specifically but i think if i show it to
you side by side its influence is clear
right when you think of wes anderson i'm
guessing the first thing you think of
is his unique visual style in fact the
uniqueness of his visual style is one of
his greatest hallmarks and yet he's a
director that is not afraid of blatantly
borrowing from the work
of great directors and great films that
he admires
he's not afraid of remixing the work of
those who have come before him
amidst the countless homages and
references in his filmography one of the
most
thorough and blatant is his recreation
of a scene from alfred hitchcock's torn
curtain in the grand budapest hotel
torn curtain one of hitchcock's less
critically acclaimed films is yet
another film
set in an eastern european country on
the brink of war
[Music]
for the grand budapest hotel anderson
collected and studied
many films that feature hotels in europe
or eastern europe as a setting in
addition to integrating many of these
influences into his work directly he
made the collection
of films available to the cast and crew
to view during production
and the fingerprints of the films in
this collection can be seen all over the
grand budapest hotel
sometimes subtly like with the silence
sometimes he'll borrow an idea
like the downhill ski chase from the
james bond film on her majesty's secret
service
but not copy the visuals directly
but some references are anything but
subtle
anderson's homage to hitchcock is
essentially a remake of the scene
but what makes such a blatant recreation
an artful homage
and not just a lazy rip-off let's take a
look
the first and most obvious element is
that anderson imbues
his version of the sequence with his own
personal visual style
even when he's essentially recreating
the same shots he recomposes them
so that they fit within his more
planometric and symmetrical style
he turns hitchcock's angled perspective
into a straight on or profile
perspective
where the compositions match most
blatantly are in places where hitchcock
is using symmetrical or planometric
compositions himself
anderson also adds his own flair to
certain moments
one particularly clever example is the
use of the bus's shade and the
reflection
to reveal surge x on his motorcycle
instead of cutting back and forth like
hitchcock does
anderson's version of the scene also
isn't a perfect match in the edit he
re-times
certain cuts and elements to fit his
film's faster pace
and he adds score to the sequence where
hitchcock has none but anderson isn't
just
using hitchcock's sequence as visual
inspiration
he's using the reference to add to the
experience of the story
here's how if you've never seen torn
curtain you'll appreciate anderson's
sequence on its own
but if you have seen torn curtain the
homage is direct enough that you'll
probably recognize the sequence if you
do you'll know how hitchcock's sequence
ends
paul newman's character successfully
evades his tale by
listening for his footsteps
anderson's homage follows the sequence
so closely that if you've seen
hitchcock's you'll probably expect the
same result but here anderson turns the
sequence on its head in a clever way
[Music]
surge x is able to catch jeff goldblum's
character
by removing his shoes so deputy kovacs
can't hear his footsteps
and i think this is what makes such a
direct and extended homage like this
artful anderson isn't just using
hitchcock's sequence because he likes it
and wants to copy it
he's using it to potentially play with
the expectations
of anyone who's seen the hitchcock film
and this
actually works both ways for someone
who's seen the grand budapest hotel
first
and then goes back and watches torn
curtain you might expect paul newman's
character to get caught
and be surprised when he goes free
having seen one
sequence doesn't spoil the other but
actually
adds to the suspense of watching it this
is why a film critic or analyst might
say that two films can be
in conversation with each other because
the experience of watching one
affects the other in this case in a
positive way
anderson does what a good video essay
does
takes another artist's work and uses it
to create something that says something
new
has a different conclusion or experience
for the viewer
or adds to the conversation if i'm going
to borrow from another artist
i like to think of it this way am i
adding to a broader conversation
or am i merely mimicking in hopes of
achieving the same thing the original
artist was
[Music]
mubi is an online streaming cinema with
a heavy focus
on curation they have a library of films
you can watch and they also have a now
showing section where they add a new
film
every day with an explanation of why
it's worth your time
their collection features arthouse
independent foreign and classic films
some of which you won't find
anywhere else mubi has introduced me to
a lot of great new films that i wouldn't
have found otherwise
and it's also given me an opportunity to
watch some older films that i've been
meaning to watch for a long time
the film i want to recommend today is
andre tarkovsky's nostalgia
nostalgia is a fascinating film and it
has some
incredible imagery and you can watch it
as a part of the movie library when you
sign up for your 30-day free trial at
movie.com thomasflight that's
mubi.com thomasflight for your extended
30 day free trial
thank you so much for watching and i
want to especially thank my patrons
right now at the five dollar level i'm
doing a special series
where i let my patrons choose a movie
for me to watch and then i review it
so if you want to get in on that you can
go to patreon.com
thomasflight